avec des premiers répondants qui occupe
une place dans la traditionnelle photo
de famille un des thèmes du g20 saute
aux yeux la pandémie et le partage des
vaccins l'hôte de la conférence déplore
que dans les pays les plus pauvres
seulement 3% de la population a été
vaccinée
job strip cents l'écart avec les pays
riches est moralement inacceptable et
mine la reprise économique selon le
premier ministre italien
[Musique]
le canada veut montrer qu'il fait ça par
le gouvernement trudeau promet dès
maintenant 10 millions de doses
supplémentaires est l'équivalent de 63
millions de doses d'ici la fin de l'an
prochain avec ce qui avait déjà été
promis la contribution canadienne
s'élève à l'équivalent de 200 millions
de doses c'est un engagement sincère on
va le faire
mais encore faut-il qu'elles se rendent
à destination selon un récent rapport
d'oxfam une faible proportion des doses
promises à l'échelle mondiale ont été
livrés je pense que on doit constater
que on n'a pas la production chez nous
on ne contrôle pas la production
c'est une première rencontre du g20 en
personne depuis le début de la pandémie
l'occasion de renouer avec des gestes
protocolaire mais surtout de consolider
des liens avec des pays alliés
mais il y a un grand absent à rome chi
zhang ping le président chinois
participe au g20 mais par vidéo la chine
est en est de loin le plus grand pays
émetteur de gaz à effet de serre de la
planète cela ne facilite pas les
pourparlers sur le climat prévue à
l'horaire demain ici madeleine les morts
et radio-canada rome